all right let's talk bachelorette is it
Khloe Kardashian no it is not breaking
news it's not Khloe Kardashian
but we had some fun with that I think
and I think I think everybody had a
little fun with it because obviously
Khloe apparently went through a big
breakup I don't know if you heard any
team Kris is a dear friend of ours and a
friend of mine in a part of bachelor
nation and there's a lot to it it
probably wouldn't be the worst show
there's some compelling arguments to be
made there but no well then who's in the
running to be our Bachelorette well I
mean honestly I think you have 20 good
candidates on stage tonight I can tell
you this for sure the decision has not
been made there is a raging debate going
on behind the camera in front of the
camera we are just like you guys we have
our opinions we all have our own I have
my own I'm fighting for my favorites
you know Mike Fleiss Rob Mills the
producers the network everyone's got
their favorites and so we're all just
battling and we battle just like you and
so I think we have a little bit of
embarrassment of riches there's some
really strong independent amazing women
that we can choose from in it it's you
know it's kind of like with Colton with
Blake or Jason cuz we've been wrong no
but you just it gives you a different
show so what we're gonna decide is who's
ready for this who can handle it who
will make a really good TV show and by
the way just I'm just gonna put this out
there whoever we choose is great whoever
we don't choose it's not that we don't
love them okay take it easy social media
[Music]